I was very disturbed when I learned
about Hive cities these massive
multi-level structures housing billions
to tens of billions of people paint a
very Grim picture of humanity the city
is from the Warhammer 40K universe and
it's a vision of a future that's pushed
to the limits with endless war toxic
factories and suffocating density humans
or pseudo humans are in this constant
struggle for resources and survival the
weird thing is we kept finding resources
comparing Hive SE to this architectural
concept called archology it's this
utopian vision for a self-sustaining and
high density City all contained within
this single Mega structure except hi
cities is the dystopian version toxins
from the city lead to a complete
ecological collapse and the structure
leads to this inherent social hierarchy
is this what's going to happen if we're
forced to think about nothing but
survival I actually made a full video on
this if you want to check it out follow
the link right here